so and so just reported this
a tweet just reported white house staff
are starting to look for jobs employers
considering them should know there are
consequences for anyone
for hiring anyone who helped trump
attack american values
find out how at the trump accountability
project
the trump accountability project says
remember what they
did we must never forget those who
furthered the trump agenda
we should welcome in our fellow
americans with whom we should welcome in
our fellow americans with whom we differ
politically
but those who took a paycheck from the
trump administration should not profit
from their efforts to tear our democracy
apart
the world should never forget those who
when faced with a decision
chose to put their money their time and
their reputations behind separating
children from their
families encouraging racism and
anti-semitism and negligently causing
the unnecessary loss
of life and economic devastation from
our country's failed response to the
covet-19 pandemic
i will give trump no
no props at all for his response to
covet 19.
it was the worst series of actions of
his presidency
but the other things on this list are
either
false or extreme exaggerations
and um that's not really the point here
though is it yeah
the point the point is
can they hear themselves do they have
any idea and incidentally
i would recommend um you know so i've
i've put myself
i've i've signed up with a with a
throwaway email account
um to find out what they're up to as
they start to be up to something
um this trump accountability project but
at the same time before you respond
here we have um alexandria ocasio-cortez
aoc
asking is anyone archiving these trump
sycophants for when they try to downplay
or deny their complicity in the future
i foresee decent possibility of many
deleted tweets writings photos in the
future
okay um with 329
000 likes yeah and just one more
before we uh talk about this your
brother eric quote tweeted aoc
in that tweet and said you should google
section a of the reserve index
perhaps there should be a minimal
history exam to let woke people into the
left you don't seem to understand the
left its history or its objectives you
sound like the other
team you aren't the left you're the
other guys
this of course is something that he and
you and i and many others have been
saying throughout
know our critique of this horrifying
nonsense that is happening on the far
left of the party is not evidence that
we are on the right it is evidence that
we are actually
over the left from when the left meant
openness
and inquiry and the ability to disagree
with people
without conflating that disagreement
with a complete
dismantling of them as human beings
so the section a of the reserve index
apparently this section a
is has been disappeared now through no
nefarious means
uh the reserve index actually i'll just
um
pull it oh god where did my thing go um
the reserve
index um just you don't have to show the
sec this is just wikipedia
um it's you know there's a lot there's a
lot here
um is
and i was going to read it but now i
can't find it
so the reserve index as opposed to the
security index the security index is the
list by the fbi of
people that the fbi considers dangerous
who might commit acts inimical to the
national defense and public safety to
the united states in time of emergency
the reserve index on the other hand
again i'm just quoting wikipedia listed
all left-wingers and individuals
suspected of being a communist by the
1950s for instance there were 5 000
names under the security index while the
reserve index had 50
000 in the chicago field office
uh some of those people were martin
luther king
and oh i feel like i don't see it here
now but i feel like robeson was on that
paul robeson yep that makes sense and um
it was
hoover uh j edgar hoover who put dr
martin luther king jr on the reserve
index
in retaliation for and again i'm just
quoting wikipedia his civil rights work
and worldwide popularity
yep um so uh it will not surprise you if
it sounds like you didn't see it but
um i saw aoc's tweet also
and could not restrain myself i had to
respond zach will you put up my
response to her i said you are an
elected representative in a
democratic republic and you are setting
the stage for retribution against fellow
citizens
for the crime of holding a different
opinion it's un-american
you should stop it and counsel others to
do the same and for anyone who doubts
that i wrote that
i apparently misspelled counsel there
are two different ways
yes you can spell it yeah um so
here's the thing there's a a battle
coming about this first of all this is a
terrible instinct this is an absolutely
appalling instinct that you are going to
hound the people leaving office
and punish them for the very fact of
being on the other side
and i mean not only does it uh forebode
truly awful possibilities
um but at the at a minimum it reveals
that they thrive on division
oh right that the the extremists
really on the left side of the
democratic party
thrive on division have no interest in
reestablishing that we're all americans
and all human and that we are all in
this together
and should be seeking a better and more
prosperous and more
equal um but not equitable
future uh it it just it puts the light
all of that they're not interested in
that
yep now i will say um trump is
far from innocent in this of course his
uh his whole locker up thing
during the 2016 campaign was appalling
for the same
reason but at some level we have to
recognize that we
as americans have every interest in
preventing this
arms race right where we treat the other
side as criminals
and we start to recognize the mechanisms
that allow this
to be justified so if you chase down
what uh
aoc goes on to say in her next tweet
you know it's about accountability and
there are these
syllogisms that are used to protect this
absolutely vile behavior which have to
do
you know you will hear um you know that
there is freedom of speech but there's
no freedom from accountability
right and on the one hand that's true on
the other hand
it's what's implied right accountability
is one thing nobody is saying
we shouldn't remember who supported whom
and frankly you and i have advocated
that one way to make the system more
sensible is to get people who say
crazy things to write it down right so
that they can remember what they once
thought
but that's very different than
collecting information on people
and then using it to adjust their
ability to earn a living
the fact is you have to leave room for
honest disagreements
i would point out that the side that is
now going around
demonizing the trump administration
and you know that term sycophants that
does not suggest that they're even
talking about people who were formally
part of it
right they're talking about people who
liked it and
are they in fact talking about 70
million trump voters right are they in
fact talking about something like that
and in a world where we are talking
about all kinds of
crazy stuff on the far left right about
how to sort of informally restructure
all of our interactions so that the
right people end up benefiting
this is just part are they talking are
they talking about us not trump voters
but people who
said with regard to his rule on for
instance critical race theory yeah
good one keep that up right and in fact
we've seen the tech platforms who are
effectively
partnered with this ideology we've seen
them
treat uh the unity movement the same way
when the unity movement was decidedly
not trump not biden yep right so um yes
the dangers here are
uh are are many and the echoes of
history
and the punitive um nature of
politics when you have a system that is
uh
less dynamic and less fairness oriented
than ours
are hard to miss yes it is
so um oh the other thing i wanted to
point out so you've got
uh the you've got these little
syllogisms about
uh you know intent doesn't matter it's
consequences that matter
right now i can defend that sentence
but i also know what it means in these
cases
and what it means cannot be defended and
there are also
obviously places in for instance the
legal system where intent does matter
well so the idea that intent doesn't
matter has been
has been used to advance the cause of
critical race
theory and you know very illiberal
practices
in so-called diversity and inclusion
trainings
where all it takes is for me to have
taken offense
to demonstrate that you were intending
to give offense and that you have racism
in your heart or whatever it is right
right
and no sorry that's not how that works
not only is it not how it works but it
basically
empowers anyone who wants to including
bad actors who wish to abuse this power
to
convict anyone they want by simply
accusing them so it is
absolutely the un you know i would argue
nothing matters
more than intent right and that doesn't
mean so intent doesn't matter
matches certain aspects of this right if
somebody uh
runs over you know your kid
right your kid is gone so in some sense
intent doesn't affect that parameter and
from the point of view of your grappling
with the loss
it doesn't matter from the point of view
of what we do about the person
who hit your kid either through
negligence
or intent it's all the difference in the
world as it must be
right you get a crazy system if you
erase these things
and so anyway one has the sense that we
are dealing either
with people who don't give a crap about
the system that they are destroying
because they actually don't agree with
us about the things that it
is built to achieve or that they don't
understand it well enough to understand
what they are unhooking
yeah and either of those is is
terrifying
and there's also a crucial distinction
between
the analogy you just gave and what we're
actually seeing which is that in the
case
that your child gets killed by someone
in a car
and you are forever after without your
child
but the person driving the car will
suffer different consequences regardless
of whether or not they were
negligent or intentionally trying to
kill someone
the fact is that a dead child
is an objective fact and that a large
number of the claims that are being made
against people
and against for instance those who you
know worked or were somehow sycophants
in the trump administration are not
objective facts
they are claims some of which are
actually very few of which are actually
falsifiable and
falsified and many of the rest are
simply these sort of
but my feelings say i'm hurt right now
and i'm offended and therefore what
you're doing is terrible
and so not only has intent being is
intent being intentionally
erased but the actual conclusion the you
know the thing
for which they would erase intent is
very much a subjective matter
and they would they would make claims uh
like you know asking for evidence of
racism self-evidence of racism
um such that you can't even believe that
the conclusion is what they say it is
yeah that's that's quite right and
you know let's put it this way there's a
mixture
the reason that people would do this is
a mixture of things some of them are
confused and some of them
are actually involved in a massive power
grab
and putting the rest of us at tremendous
risk um
that isn't theirs to create yeah and the
problem is
i keep running into this which is in
order to protect ourselves from these
kinds of instincts
right one has to
convey something subtle and increasingly
i think
boring and so it's very hard to get
people
to focus on why we have
counter-intuitive protections why we
don't go after the other party when they
leave
office and we feel that what they've
done in office is vile
right very hard to explain these things
and the
idea that we need to get enough of us on
board with remembering what those
structures are for
and how they work when they work and
what has happened when they failed and
why that's bad
i just can't imagine that conversation
occurring
broadly enough to to reverse the
trajectory
you know i i did see
a hopeful sign there was enough traffic
uh
in the reverse where aoc was
trying to incite people to to start
cataloging who
who had committed these crimes well as i
began with it's not just her there's an
actual you know page
and people are like i've seen it all
over here it's basically it's the
what was that what was that spreadsheet
that was started during early me too
the oh yes the bad it wasn't bad
it was something men in hollywood the
nasty men yeah whatever it was
uh where this this journalist or would
be journalist i don't remember what
basically said just send me all of your
all of your names send me the name of
anyone who has been naughty
and i'm i i how could i fact check it so
i'll just put that up there and then
publicize this
this spreadsheet and you know of course
it took out a number of good people as
well as you know presumably revealing
some
truly heinous figures but the point is
an informal system like that invites
abuse
of course it does um i would also point
out uh
long before candace owens was well known
um
she was involved in an effort to put
together
a uh basically i hope i have this right
it was like a doxing
site um so anyway this theme keeps
getting reinvented
because it's the last presumably uh this
was
it's a little murky as to what it was i
don't want to say because i'm not
certain about the details of it but
it's a it's it's a canonical where
people will keep reinventing the idea of
panel
punishing those people on the other side
but i would point out okay
it is very rare these days
that people on the left will invoke the
comparison
between trump and hitler but there was a
long period there where it was not the
least bit rare
to hear that assertion and i think the
point is the idea
that in an environment where you're
going to get stuff that wrong
right that you are then going to go
about punishing people on the other side
for
disagreeing with you that's preposterous
well i gather you haven't heard that
rogan is the new hitler
that seems unlikely i mean you've met
him he
doesn't really seem all that hitler no
really not but that would be exactly
what he would do wouldn't it
luring us into a false sense of security
by being so goddamn decent that would
cover it like
nothing else yeah um all right
so uh no i've actually seen um people
beginning to
suggest that rogan might be hitler
i can personally assure you that he is
course not but but i mean you know to
the point that people
once once you've established the need
for the devil and you know we talked
about this for the
when we were talking about hoffer's book
on mass movements
um that you know this is akin to a
religion every good religion
every successful religion needs some
kind of a devil
um that if if hitler if you know the the
guy he would manage to convince some
number of people
was hitler is now out of here and
like who are you going to put up on the
mantle of hitlerness
well you know rogan is apparently one of
those apparently on the
list it's incredible yeah
um yeah it's really shocking but you
need a devil
[Music]